c'est une triste histoire de harcèlement
en ligne à caractère raciste qui a fini
au tribunal
certains nous ont même appelé la ligue
du lol des républicains en mai 2010huit
sun l'âme un étudiant d'origine
vietnamienne à l'époque militant au
parti les républicains décident de
quitter cette formation politique
il est alors victime d'une campagne
d'insultés sur un groupe facebook de la
part d'internautes qui ne connaît même
pas des injures des expressions comme
manger du chien niaque
tout y était pour humilier le jeune
homme sur le thème du racisme anti
asiatique le 11 septembre dernier sun
même régis et avant l'audience du procès
en appel
quand on pense aux insultes il ya la
tristesse et puis après la tristesse il
ya aussi énormément de colère puisque on
ne se dit que c'est intolérable ce qui
nous arrive pas ce qui m'est arrivé est
évidemment à cela s'ajoute le sentiment
d'exaspération sur le banc des accusés
et dit denis un ancien conseiller
régional républicains à volx dans le
lubéron il est considéré comme
l'instigateur principal de ce cyber
harcèlement aux côtés d'une vingtaine
d'autres internautes républicain en
première instance le 17 octobre 2019
l'accusé avait été condamné à trois mois
de prison avec sursis un stage de
citoyenneté et 8000 euros de dommages et
intérêts deux jours après la
condamnation est dit denis avait appelé
seule lame en se faisant passer pour le
maire de volx et en le menaçant
l'élu avait finalement démissionné sonne
là mais toujours éprouvé par cette
histoire je suis marqué encore de ses
horreurs je n'ai rien oublié
il faut bien comprendre cette affaire
qu'il n'y a absolument aucune raison et
que c'est juste de la haine pure
malheureusement en france on manque de
moyens que ce soit au niveau de la
police ou à haut niveau de la justice
c'est pour ça qu'il ya seulement une
personne qui aujourd'hui prévenu mais
y'aura plus en avoir 10 ou 15 de
nombreux élus dont valérie pécresse ou
encore des députés insoumis ont soutenu
le jeune homme et des associations
antiracistes sos racisme la licra le
mrap se sont constituées parties civiles
dans le procès interpellé quelqu'un en
lui disant petits nems grain de riz
tu manges du chien c'est pas anodin
c'est une stigmatisation à raison de
l'origine
vraie ou supposée donc ça doit être
poursuivie ce doit être condamné et on
est heureux au mrap que les populations
d'origine asiatique face de plus en plus
appel aux associations et saisissent de
plus en plus la justice pour que leur
dignité soit reconnue la sentence a été
confirmée en appel
edit donniez à l'époque avait dit
regretter ces propos s'ils avaient
offensé quelqu'un nous l'avons contacté
il a répondu ne pas vouloir s'exprimer
pour le moment pour des raisons
procédurales ce procès illustre selon
sean lam une prise de conscience des
jeunes d'origine asiatique
moi je suis de la deuxième génération
donc de ceux qui sont nés en france et
nous sommes beaucoup plus politisé et si
tenté que nous ne le soyons pas nous
sommes néanmoins beaucoup plus que
sensible et sensibilisé à cette lutte
contre le racisme
ma lutte ce n'est pas simplement celle
des asiatiques c'est une lutte pour tout
le monde que ce soit l'antisémitisme
l'islamophobie ou la détestation des
autres minorités de récents procès de
violences à caractère raciste envers les
asiatiques ont émaillé l'actualité fin
les associations recensées une agression
de ce type tous les deux jours en ile de
france
la communauté asiatique a plusieurs fois
défiler sa dernière année pour réclamer
davantage de sécurité
ce jugement vient donc confirmer que
cette communauté se mobilise pour que
cesse l'impunité